ين جديدتين كبيرتين في منطقه جباليه
البلد حسبنا الله ونعم
الو انا رسالتي للعالم يا عمي شوفنا احنا
في دمار مش قادرين يا عمي نطول
كمان الشهداء تعينا المصابين اللي مش
قادرين
نطول احنا هلقيت المصاب جو مش قادرين
نطوله بالشت كمان ساعه
حيوانات ستهدف ستهدف حيوانات مدنيين والله
ما نا في اي تنظيم احنا ما ادرين هدار
بتنزل بطلع دخن الا الدار اللي قبنا بتنزل
الا السوق انضرب ضربوا عش هو مره واحده مش
ه حده خلص الواحد يعرف يطلع يطول المصابين
قاعد يضربوا ع
بجن اجلاء المزيد من الاصابات
والشهداء في هذه المجزره الاسرائيليه
الجديده التي ترتكب بحق
هنا انتشال المزيد من الشهداء كما تشاهدون
الان شهداء عشرات الشهداء في المجزر تين
اه ناس مدنيين هيني شايف معي بواريد انسان
مدني هيني اطفال اطفال نساء البيت يمكن في
100 كلهم اطفال ونساء حد عايش جو بطلب
النجده
لا احد يستطيع الدخول في هذه اللحظات الى
هذا المكان او
مشاهده او اجلاء اي
اصابات الحمد لله على
سلامتكم ايش اللي صار ايش اللي صار والله
قاعدين في
دورنا دخيل ب الاشار بيع ايوه والله سمعنا
الصوت جينا من البلد ننقذ لقيناه كلهم تحت
الانقاذ فيش غير بنت صغيره طلعنا شء مزيد
من الشهداء في مجدره عائله ابو خليفه التي
تزامنت مع مجدره عائله ابو ورده في بلده
جباليا النزله هذا القصف المدفع بالتزامن
هنا يحمل هذا شهيده شهيده شهيده طفله
شهيده من هذه المجزره بعد تكفينها والبحث
عن مكان
لدفنها اصابه حرجه لاحد
المواطنين
في هذه المجزره
[تصفيق]
الجديده يختنق يختنق هذا المنزل ايضا
مجاور هذا المنزل
مجاور ايش يا حاجه الحمد لله على
سلامت ايوه ايوه ايوه حبيبي اي هنا اجلاء
المزيد من الشهداء مزيد من
الشهداء ايو
ايو واحد على بعد امتار من المجزره مجزره
عائله ابو ورده هنا مجزره جديده يرتكبها
ترتكبها قوات الاحتلال في منزل عائله خيفه
كما تشاهدون الان مجزر في نفس الوقت
صاروخان ضربان هذا هذا المكان والمكان
الاخر كما تشاهدون انتشال الشهداء هنا في
بلده جباليه
البلد
الله